earlier our own damn bond Gino alongside
our friend pastor Daryl Scott spoke on
Capitol Hill during a hearing on police
practices let's take a look the
law-abiding members of society would be
directly threatened by the absence of
police or the inability of police to
respond to criminal activities and in
many cases would endeavor to take the
law into their own hands to ensure that
their safety and well-being removing
these heroes from your communities in my
community will do nothing but ensure
chaos and destruction police officers
are the front lines putting themselves
between the evildoers among us and the
honest hardworking Americans just
yearning for some security and
prosperity in a small slice of Americana
all right joining us now for reaction we
do have pastor Daryl Scott Fox News
contributor damn Bungie no congressman
Republican great state of Florida Matt
Gaetz is with us he's in the committee
let me start with you Dan bond Geno you
talked about and I watched the passion
the heroes did we forget well everybody
was racing down the stairwells on 9/11
o1 the cops
the firemen the first responders EMT
they were racing up to save lives at a
lot of them knew darn well the odds
weren't good for them coming home that
night and even left messages to loved
ones did we forget the 99% damn Bungie
no looks like it not the people on this
panel Sean and you know I think a lot of
people watching have an either sadly
many have you know Sean no offense of
the people in the media business you
know I love you and Matt and Daryl but
the finest men and women I've ever met
in my life were in law enforcement ever
and the fact that they've been
apologized yeah I agree with you because
so many I know you feel like if you do
it and they agree with you and that's
why I knew you wouldn't take offense to
it these are the finest men and women
I've ever met I mean did we forget that
again and then that truck seven ESU
truck seven that lost so many members on
9/11 you know Sean they turned out of
the precinct I used to work in in the 75
you know how often I think to myself
when I was a young rookie police officer
how many of those guys I walked by I was
a rookie they probably didn't say much
to me because they were next door
casually walked by in a parking lot of
the 75 that are dead that aren't around
anymore
I think about that all the time and we
so casually moved on and and shown that
ones it's not to distract at all from
the purpose of the hearing today
listen police reform sitting down with
the unions and focusing on getting rid
of bad apples like to do what is that's
a great idea you and I agree stop the
chokehold Alishan life as an imminent
danger we do martial arts
what's all we talk about when we're
together Sean all the yeah throwing them
overboard the cops
it was just I felt some of the Democrats
not all really really did a disservice
yesterday by turning to attack the cops
it really was unnecessary we had enjoyed
bipartisan unity with this all right let
me go to Pastor Scott pastor you know
I'm looking at Seattle tonight you have
now talk of armed volunteers of Antipa
to guard their cop free zone and taking
over precincts you know for 32 years
there was a show on television I like
call cops there's a show on the weekend
called live PD with Dan Abrams you know
what I like about those shows we have
cameras on but which I think every cop
needs a body cam every cruiser needs a
camera
let's keep everybody honest let's
protect citizens let's protect the
police that doing a good honest job
every day and protecting and serving we
learn a lot about how hard these jobs
are for these shows I like those shows I
think we learn about what they have to
deal with every day and the good people
that do respond properly and how to use
respond properly it's all on videotape
that frankly that will help keep the
abusive elements out of policing you're
absolutely right and what we're seeing
today as you demonstrated earlier with
these this latest round of riots is that
people are going to take the log to
their own hands when it comes to time to
defend themselves simply because of this
stand down order that some of these
Democratic politicians are issuing we
against the police listen I'm glad our
president is a law-and-order president
and every law-abiding citizen of this
country stands behind him
in stating that you know we do have to
tinker you know the thing about but
pleases this and there are bad apples
even as my brother Dan ban Gino said you
know if you put a bad apple in a barrel
of good apples the good apples don't
turn the bad I feel good but then one
bad apple can turn the good apples bad
so we want to get out the bad apples you
know in a concerted effort to eliminate
the bad apples but we can't throw the
baby out with the bathwater as I said
earlier today in Congress the police
forces job is to protect and serve and
we rely on them to do that on a regular
basis man so we're not going to allow
the Democratic Party to turn us against
police for political purposes you know
Matt I'm watching this to the end I'm
watching you in particular and I'm
watching the interactions here and I'm
thinking you know look at what's
happening in Seattle and around the
country
you know canceling cops and live PD I
think we need more cameras cameras
showed us the truth all right didn't lie
to us would with with mr. Floyd for
example sure defund the police abolish
ice disarm Americans and then surrender
our cities to the antifa mob if this is
the rulebook for the new woke topia
count me out I think that today the
reporting that you've just indicated
shows that like an Tifa has now
designated Seattle their capital and
it's going to be bad for the citizens
there what we need to do is focus on
supporting the good police isolating and
removing the bad police and I'm hopeful
Shawn that we could actually work across
party lines on this this shouldn't be a
partisan issue we should work on it
together and I and thanks to the great
work that Dan did representing police
and that Pastor Scott did representing
his community and so many around the
country I actually think we took a very
productive step today